the other day yes sir I must feel bad
you and bringing it up but well I won't
tell you who it was that would be the
real dick move yeah but this guy who I
work with had toilet paper oh no like
well I guess he had like used like done
like the seat cushion yeah and I'm just
like I see him go sit down with a big
long thing at all of us pants and I'm
like Oh something has to be done you
know what I mean you can't that's that's
when you angry at them for putting you
now in this position but there's no way
I can't do it it's too much so I kind of
sit down and I just go and I just start
pointing with you and then he finally
sees it and it was just awful you know
what I mean I think things are not the
same between us anymore and I'm waiting
and then I'm thinking is he is it gonna
be a little poo on the end of it you
know like but there wasn't there was
thank God that that's like what has
never told this is the first I've spoken
of it and I even I'm not gonna say who
it is but I even feel bad even bringing
it up well you know what they say the
more you talk about something the less
weight you give to it the more it
deflates the serious yeah so maybe this
is hope this is not too deep so yeah do
you have a best gift that you've ever
received
there was this camera that came out in
like 1987 and it was made by
fisher-price is called the pxl mm video
camera it was a video camera huh but it
used audio tapes it was really weird but
it made these really cool like pixelated
movies that and it was like just enough
to like get started and make a thing and
my friends and I made so many videos on
this awesome we strapped it to his
remote-control car and ran chased the
dog around like we did these full
sketches that we would not you know
cause you couldn't edit or anything that
would just be like we'd shoot it in
order and then these like huh like cut
but I would say that's like the first I
was like the birth of me like making
videos that's cool is that gifted by
parents Santa by Santa
oh yes and my mom will still do that
she'll like write some stuff my stepmom
does that and if we acknowledge it she
gets really upset
no it's from Santa and then she has
gifts that are from her my dad yeah my
mom my mom does a crazy thing too where
she just starts putting names from
different people so she'll be like I'll
be like oh I got a shirt from Coolio
that's pretty great my parents pretty
funny that's hilarious I want to start
doing that now this is from Karina long
how do you stop from slapping a [ __ ]
and she asked us a few times so she
really needs to do a [ __ ] slapping
spray she can get to work and do things
yeah I feel like she tweeted this so
many times so her hands would stay busy
so that she didn't slap I don't know
it's I mean it's a daily struggle I
won't lie about that yeah well you know
there's several support groups for that
kind of thing find chat rooms I think
the Internet is a great place to find
like-minded people yeah you just have to
tell yourself don't slap a [ __ ] don't
slap a [ __ ] it's kind of my mantra got
positive affirmation for you on the
daily don't just don't slap a [ __ ] okay
team grace face if you could change your
hands into anything but your own normal
hands what would you change this to mark
is very balanced and work and play it
would change it's a dick just have no
it's like don't forget to masturbate to
pee there's something there about that
being a really great Halloween costume
just be a giant dick with posts post-it
note is that's a good your dick is a
good place to put a post-it note because
you won't lose you'll be like oh right
right do laundry never gonna ignore your
dick
a little whiteboard on there welcome to
your challenge mark open your eyes okay
first of all who are it better
adults in monochromatic there's no
challenge we just wanted this moment to
happen right now me what I went to put
this on I was like yeah I've worn this
before I can't even like joke about this
this is not my first time in an all
green sweat suit anyway because
everyone's going Gumby this year because
it is the the festive season of
Christmas this challenge is a nacho Jeep
original usually we take a challenge
that pre-exists on YouTube and we try
and make it dumber than it already is
but this is a complete original it's
called human Christmas tree alright and
what we are going to do is transform
ourselves into human Christmas trees
okay how we do it is as follows we are
we have our tree bases already and what
we're gonna have to do is when go is
screamed we have to race to put on four
candy canes for ornaments a Christmas
tree skirt we're gonna go waist up on
this so the skirt goes around your waist
be careful about tying it apparently
it's not big enough so all right best of
luck to you
we have garland we need to wrap
ourselves in a star for the top and we
also have lights
once everything is on and the lights are
plugged in we each of a plug okay you
scream Merry Christmas and the first
person to do that is the winner okay
okay
I'm just like I'm just kind of coming up
with a plan here are you going straight
over
yeah there's no order you can come up
with your own order okay okay so you
understand the rules I do I'm a little
nervous about this but I shouldn't be
because this is the cleanest game we've
ever played on not too deep this also
the most festive stage possible for this
challenge is the set of CBGB here
installed in the YouTube space yes if
this doesn't scream Christmas I mean
look this says Merry suicide the actual
wall
from the original see behavior yeah and
before that this is been challenged
before he's not go there about yeah this
is the actual walls from CBGB and then
originally before that it was the actual
manger that Jesus was born in so I know
those wise men were drinking that Merl
like crazy and they just puked
everywhere god bless him okay we
understand the rules I think so alright
producer-director the one that kicks it
off yes I always make me anxious because
I feel like if they fall they break yeah
they should have waited on the christmas
balls they're hindering my movements
yeah I'm Way too excitable yeah this is
a good squat workout garland acquitting
what the hell has never happened
go go go go go no no second lights got
it
I'm a tree Murano I already won your
stars on backwards how embarrassing but
you I like my you pin the candy canes
directly on to your teats oh well you
know I mean it's the Lord's birthday
after all I was gonna put the balls near
my balls but yeah but there's no time
for art and a cynic when you're racing
to become a human Christmas tree I don't
think this is fair you had time to plan
this out and plan your trip no I didn't
that's the biggest I had time did I use
it correctly to know which one I won
this never happens and we didn't break
anything no that's a shock this doesn't
seem like a smart thing nope go check
out barely political over on their
channel on YouTube and go listen to the
full interview with mark over on iTunes
or SoundCloud not too deep thanks for
being here
Merry Christmas everybody and also the
other holidays that you write that are
not just Christmas I don't want to be
Christmases that's what we do here on
now should you just pick one thing and
make all the other things feel small fav
nail polish color I like a UH like a
robin's egg blue oh okay okay
very specific and said without
hesitation
[Music]